well with us now is Andrew Wilson who's
author of Alexander McQueen blood
beneath the skin and amber groffle and
who is the fashion director for The
Daily Mirror welcome to you both Andrew
as a McQueen was never short of
headlines during his lifetime but what
struck me looking at your book is how
little we actually knew about the man
during his lifetime in particular his
dark aside one extent was that the man
himself and to what extent was he shaped
by the environment he worked it well he
was one of those characters who was very
much an enigma he was a very private
person he kept lots of dark secrets so
even though he would go out into the
world and as you say quite rightly
generate these extraordinary headlines
there were very very few people who knew
him I worked very very closely with his
family to build up a picture of this
very complex individual and obviously
the material was very very dark at times
but fortunately the family have have
read the book their support the book
even though it contains some quite
difficult material and we've seen some
shots there or some of his shows to what
extent did that character shape his
desires do you think because of course a
lot of them were very controversial well
I think he saw beauty in the grotesque
and I think if you look at the title of
the exhibition Savage Beauty he was very
inspired by nature and you saw the
beauty of nature in his work but you
also saw the wild savagery of nature and
I think that was the two sides to his
character that came through in his work
and I think sometimes although he shows
was spectacular sometimes they were what
they were dark I mean you know jack the
ripper highland rape led to some of his
collections that he is that because sort
of fashion has gone beyond being pretty
if you like and it has to be shocking
and almost unpleasant in some way I
don't think it has to be I think if you
look at most successful designers they
are just presenting beautiful wearable
clothes I think where Alexander McQueen
was different was that his work was it
was it wasn't just fashion went beyond
fashion it was art and I think he was
presenting something went much whether
went beyond just presenting exact point
you know
had heroin chic elsewhere and all the
rest of it is at the point that if you
want to claim to be an artist you've got
to as it were be slightly sick I didn't
think he had that level of
self-consciousness this really was his
personality he always said his
collections were very autobiographical a
great deal of his life was very very
dark he had some very traumatic
childhood experiences that shaped him
for the rest of his life such as when he
was nine or ten he started to be
sexually abused by his brother-in-law
the same man who beat up his elder
sister so I talked about in the book how
from that moment onwards he wanted to
try to you know construct form a
psychological armor if you like a way
that he could protect his sister and
women in general you know he said I
always want women to be afraid I want
people to be afraid of the women I dress
you know he wanted people to to be quite
startled and scared of these creations
but did that make him stand out or are
there other you know the designers we
think of as being creative genius you
took their about creating beautiful
clothes but the ones we really sit up
and watch do they have similarly sort of
damage backgrounds or things that kind
of propel them well it's the kind of
tortured genius arguments I guess isn't
it there is an if you look at many
artists that they have a dark side to
their character he hit me he was
undeniably a genius and you could argue
is that these two things come
hand-in-hand do you have to kind of have
that edge to a personality in order to
be that creative and yet although this
is probably our I understand that the
Victorian a bird didn't want your book
associated whether they won't sell it in
their shop apparently yes so they
ordered six hundred copies and then I
heard the order was cancelled you don't
know why I don't know why for what
reason my own might I suspect is my own
suspicion is that McQueen the company
want to distance themselves from McQueen
the man does that take away from ya
McQueen the man then because and the
exhibition because it kind of sanitize
it
I don't think they've sold 70,000
tickets because what the reason they
stole seven together apparently they've
sold some tickets already and I think
that's because of the person and that's
because of the story that we're
discussing here now I think if you take
that away you wouldn't have sold all
those tickets well some 2,000 people
going to see this now so what is his
legacy to the bash his legacy um I think
he pushed boundaries I think the fact
that at this point I've already made
that he saw beauty in the grotesque I
think we kind of look at the dockside to
his character the light side his
character badly he be blurred those
boundaries and I think I think that's
his legacy what are you writing and
really do so will we still be talking
about him in 20 years time I think he
completely changed the silhouette so the
reason why people talk about him in
terms of fashion is because he lowered
the waistline you know these these
things called bump stirs and that's that
sort of went right down to the high
street and all the you know young kids
around the world were worrying very low
slung jeans and trousers and he was
responsible for that good oh that but
yes away from that I mean has the
fashion world exploited the damage
genius that Wars McQueen no ultimate
well I think actually they're trying to
pull away from that so I think there's a
bit of them I think he started out and
have their cake and eat it yeah is it
that he had the pain on the genius and
they just want to keep the genius of it
yes it was about he was the on voluntary
of the fashion world and then he became
one of them he was embraced by them he
became one of them and now they may be
trying to change the story a little bit
but how do you change the story from
here there and well by only talking
about certain elements and forgetting
other elements to the story but it's you
know the reason why people are going to
see the exhibition is because of his
life and what he achieved and and where
he came from I mean generally speaking
though is there pressure from the
fashion world you know on people like
this I mean are they exploiting
designers it's an incredible amount of
pressure in 1996 when he became designer
in chief as you're born she suddenly he
wasn't just designing his own collection
he wasn't just doomed to two year he was
doing the pet reporter shows as well
that's for collections
year suddenly you have all these people
working with you everybody is relying on
you and should come up with an amazing
show every time I know she goes with it
and it's a huge business you know it's a
multi-million pound brand No so there
were certain vested interests at stake
here and as we all know you could be out
of fashion overnight cool okay thank you
very very much